- This is the frontline
of the immigration war
in America right now.
That's Mexico.
- The border towns
are not a place
that you would wanna
come and visit.
- Then why we going?
I don't want people to not
know how hard this struggle is.
You wanted your baby
to be born in America,
the greatest place.
How many people do you think
you've brought over to America?
- [Man] Thousands of people.
- When we call
the Border Patrol,
we put the cameras down.
- I heard yesterday
they deported
an eight-year-old
Guatemalan girl
and her three kids.
(laughing)
$21 billion to build
a wall right there.
I could do it if I had to
but on the bright side
the Olympic Mexican
pole vaulting team
is number one in
the world right now.
People think United Airlines
treats their passengers bad.
They're never gonna
shove a poke up your ass
and stuff you in the
overhead compartment
for a couple weeks.
I went on Tinder and
I swiped with somebody
on the other side of the wall.
That's the biggest
(beep) in history.
- [Narrator] Jeff Ross
Roasts the Border,
November 16th on Comedy Central.
- Damn, this guy.
What are you celebrating?
Cinco de Mayonnaise?
Hey everybody, I'm Jeff Ross.
If you like what you just watch,
Be sure to watch the actual spel
when it airs.
Jeff Ross Roasts the Border
Comedy Central, November 16, 10.
Assuming you're not deported by.